joining us right here on the rich eisen
show once again um
and the mercedes-benz vans phone line is
uh one of the best at talking politics
and
talking uh about numbers
that there's anybody on television and i
love watching him on election nights on
msnbc and on nbc news steve kornacki who
will be on football night in america on
sunday night on nbc and on peacock here
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line how
are you steve
rich i'm doing great this is a a fun
time of the year it's nice to talk to
you yes last time i spoke to you i was
in connecticut you were in japan i was
hosting tokyo gold and i asked you how
many pairs of khakis that you brought to
uh to the olympics that was the last
time you and i spoke i'm sure you recall
that i still have the pants i know that
that's good that's good to know so um so
how do you go about uh figuring out all
of the uh possibilities for for what's
going on uh in the nfl uh playoff race
walk me through your process that you
get ready for sunday night this is um
i got to tell you our our huge huge um
uh assist to us from pro football focus
pff our our data partner um yeah these
guys are really on top of their game and
and um
learned a lot working with them it's a
it's a very new way for me to kind of
watch sunday games um and to prep for it
really but it's it's just sort of um on
sunday afternoon i'll be sitting there
at any given moment kind of jotting down
who's ahead in every game and looking at
the okay if it finishes this way what's
it going to do to the wild card race
what's it going to do to the division
title race what's it going to do to the
top seed race and you know if this one
game switches how is it going to change
and just being aware of all the uh all
the contingencies and um
and we can find a number for for
everything and we can watch them you
know kind of bounce around all day
sunday it's um it's a real it's exciting
it's a lot to juggle but uh have a blast
doing it well i guess let's start with
uh mixing both of your parlances here
let's start with the game in los angeles
county last night right um
how did how did the chargers loss affect
their
chances of making the playoffs based on
your numerals and numbers right in front
of you steve yeah not um not too
significantly in terms of making the
playoffs they're down to we have them
down to a 69 percent chance
to make the playoffs now that number had
been at uh 76 coming in so it's a
a small hit for the playoff loss the the
big loss for the chargers is the
division title possibility um you know
win that game over to chiefs last night
they got a real shot
at winning the division instead now it's
it's the chiefs really in in the
driver's seat in the uh not just in the
afc west now if you look at that top
seed race the chiefs um we've been
watching their number just rise every
week the chiefs are at a 33 shot right
now to get the top seed in the afc oh my
gosh so one in three shot
of them having the entire playoffs come
through arrowhead and that number i
imagine improved
vastly with that overtime win on
thursday night same with their division
hopes right i mean yeah absolutely and i
think that look the chiefs are playing
so great right now you just look like
it's you know they're kind of back
obviously um the chiefs we we used to
know the problem they've got looking at
that top seed is right now the tie
breakers
the conference record would potentially
be the tiebreaker if you had a three-way
tie there um they're three games behind
the pats in the loss column
in terms of the conference record they
also have that head-to-head loss to
tennessee earlier in the year so they're
they've got to get a game up i think on
both tennessee and new england so it's
not just win out for kc they're gonna
need one or both they're gonna need both
of new england and tennessee to lose a
game which is why that's as low as 33
even though it's it's high look 33
with three games to go is something the
chiefs would have signed for when they
were three and four but um that's why
that number isn't any higher is because
you're factoring in the fact that
they're if they're in any other heads-up
tie break uh with tennessee obviously
head to head knocks them out and if
they're in a multiple mosh pit tie break
and conference record as a tiebreaker
then they're their previous losses to
the chargers and obviously
um you know uh there are other losses
like the ones to tennessee the one to
baltimore one at buffalo that's that's
what's holding them down right now yeah
and meanwhile i mean talk about a
turnaround you got the you know the pats
sitting at two and four
in the middle of october now looking at
a 37 percent shot the best of anybody in
the afc at the one seat and and the
thing the patriots have again besides
the uh the win streak right now seven
and one conference record you know and
the win over tennessee so the pats get
the head-to-head over tennessee
and three games in the in the lost
column against the kansas city for that
tiebreaker seven and one so yeah i mean
their losses to dallas and tampa those
are the losses that i guess you want to
have and new orleans
that's it they're only conference loss
to money the other conference yep
okay so um
of the teams that are
are uh on the outside looking in right
now in the afc we call it look i don't
know who came up with this steve as you
know i've been involved with the nfl
since 2003 and day in day out and
sportscenter from 96 on i don't know who
came up with the phrase in the hunt but
we here at the rich eisen so we call it
sniffing it that's the way we refer to
it those teams who are sniffing it
because they're sniffing they're
sniffing the playoffs um those who are
sniffing it in the afc eight on down
which which team has the best chance
percentage-wise of making the playoffs
right now it's it's changed a little bit
this week and i think it's the the covid
situation that's done it if we've been
having this conversation monday morning
the answer would have been cleveland
cleveland by a few points over
cincinnati
cleveland obviously just
decimated all sorts of question marks
around
around the kovitz situation and what's
happened is we've seen cleveland's
chances that the probability on paper um
of winning the game this weekend against
las vegas we've seen their chances
plummet by about 20 points this week as
all this coveted news has come out and
what that's done is it's dropped their
overall chances of getting that wild
card down to 41 percent which is now the
same number as cincinnati so you're
looking at cleveland cincinnati with an
equal shot they're both sitting there
you know cleveland right now in the 8th
spot cincinnati in the nine spot they
both have that 41 percent shot um you
know cleveland would be in better
position i think at full strength going
into this game against the raiders but
if they don't get the win this weekend
obviously they're in big trouble
national political correspondent of nbc
news and a man who will be doing all
this with fresh new numbers on sunday
night football football night in america
on nbc sports and peacock steve kornacki
here on the rich eisen show let's turn
our attention to the nfc you've got not
one not two but three ten and three
teams sitting atop and not just any
teams but the defending super bowl
champs two guys who were 12 in the mvp
race in rogers and brady who do you have
with the best chance entering week 15
nfc games of being the top seed there
right now yeah
right now it is green bay but i mean
it's 43
for the packers to get the top seed it's
41
for the bucks to get the top seed um i
think it's you look at it two ways here
number one just where are they right now
the bucks have excuse me the packers
have the tie breakers right now um it's
that conference record you know the
eight and two is green bay nfc mark
right now tampa is six and three
so they would get that tie breaker and i
think if it came to it green bay would
likely have the next tie breaker that
would be the common games um they would
also have the tiebreaker there when you
play it out for both teams they also
each one of them has
tampa bay in fact has the easiest
remaining schedule of any team in the
nfl
but i think green bays is like the third
or fourth easiest so they both have um
on paper pretty manageable paths to win
out
okay and what about the cowboys where do
they sit right now for you uh they made
the big move for the cowboys was
obviously get that win against
washington sunday and in the driver's
seat pretty much got the the division
under wraps to actually get the top seed
five percent chance right now they're uh
we got arizona at 10 and dallas at five
what about the nfc west how big of w was
the rams over the cardinals on monday
night for that
calculation and the niners obviously are
still potentially in the mix right here
well although deep down but what do you
got for me on that front for the enemies
i mean the rams now 97
obviously to make the playoffs they're
solidified there in terms of the
division uh it actually
so many of these divisions are basically
settled right now i think the the nfc
west
on paper might be the uh the third most
competitive uh arizona's got an 88 shot
uh still of winning the division so um
yeah the rams are still a a
kind of a long shot there but what they
did obviously was just really i think
sure up their uh their playoff position
well they're only one back is there any
any numbers to support why 88 percent um
and and only i guess a smaller person
much smaller percentage for the rams
right there
any anything is there a tie break we're
not we're not seeing on that if it comes
to that strength of victory the
conference record is the same right now
it comes to that strength of victory one
yeah which i think would be next right
now arizona would have the uh it would
be significantly better than the rams
there okay fantastic there's so much i i
i i love this sort of stuff steve and
you're so you're you're terrific at it
so i guess let's just i'll throw you a
curveball if you don't mind good you've
handled curveballs um
if you could compare urban meyer's head
coaching tenure to a political career
who's would it be what do you got for me
on that front oh boy well let me where
my mind
a campaign a a presidential campaign of
somebody's urban meyer's nfl coaching
tenure whose presidential campaign does
that remind me i'll give you an
a fellow ohioan okay
john glenn
okay i'll fight what is that
can't miss yeah president you know the
astronaut the hero yeah can't miss 1984
presidential candidate got in the race
and from that moment forward everything
that could go wrong went wrong i think
technically that campaign may still be
in debt today
wow what about what about giuliani's
presidential campaign yeah you know
that's not that i was looking for the
ohio connection but i think the
republican side would go rudy okay there
you go we got to be fair and balanced
you know i'm sorry i know that somebody
else's network's a phraseology but i
figured i'd just give you that idea
right there i mean yeah that one was the
other rudy one i remember was 55 million
dollars and one delegate
well um it's i don't know how much
urban's five-year contract was
but let's just say it was
like 10 million bucks a year maybe
that's 50 million in two wins
you know you know what i'm saying like
that's close
you know i i i gotta say which one of
those i'm trying to you know we gotta
factor in inflation a little bit
yeah i mean you could try that one on
for size at some point you know whenever
you want to cross streams of of the
things you are expert in uh thanks for
the time steve let's do this more often
as uh as as the playoffs uh heat up and
all that good stuff let's do that happy
to talk to you right back at you that's
steve kornacki right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here